well let's get reaction now from the
founder and director of operation black
vote and the former chair of the race
district units
advisory group lord wally simon woolley
thank you
very much indeed for joining us lord
woolley uh
what what lessons or legacies do you
draw from
the tragedy of george floyd
i hope there'll be lessons learned i
think it could be
an historical moment i mean first and
foremost i was
extremely pleased for the family of
george floyd
and for america but also potentially
globally
and i was particularly impressed by
their president biden's
um remarkable statement straight after
the guilty verdict in which he said that
that he and america must confront
systemic racism
head on and now these are dramatic words
and i have to say adam in stark contrast
to what we heard in the
house of commons yesterday with the race
equality report that has
fundamentally denied systemic racism
this isn't a moment to be in denial this
is a moment of
such deep reflection that the
outcomes of that reflection could be
transformative and lift barriers
and lift inequalities that have
persisted
for many many decades this is a moment
whether or not this country will seize
it is
is um not clear but in america
they have set their stall full square
on confronting a deep scar in american
society
it is a very deep scar in american
society to a society founded
to a certain extent economically on
slavery and and then which actually had
segregation written into law
uk obviously was involved in in slavery
but
it's had a different history since then
so to what extent do you think we should
draw parallels between
the situation we must draw we must draw
parallels log we had the
the biggest and longest civil unrest
on race ever in this country hundreds of
thousands of
i was impressed by seeing your pictures
adam when you see you saw
hundreds of thousands of young people
white and black
demanding change and the government
report from tony saw said that these
young men and women
that were hopeful that demanded were
well-meaning idealists but wrong in
their assertion
that structural racism existed now
that trounced upon their hopes it
trounced upon
the lived experiences that have been as
you know you've covered it
on a daily basis the structural
inequalities laid bare by covert 19
in education in health in housing in the
criminal justice system with a
heavy price that black asian and
minority
communities have paid um as i said look
this should be a 1945 moment you know
after the world war
where you think big you think bold you
think brave because you've recognized
the
systemic inequalities the stomach
changes that are needed
this is what this country demands this
is what these young people
want but it needs honesty it needs
leadership from number 10 down the
street and all the political parties
adam not denial if you deny
systemic problems then there's no
systemic change
this is our time to tell these young
people that marched on the streets
we're listening and we'll learn and
what happened to george floyd has not
been a million miles here
in all those areas that i explained and
will do
something about it do you think the seal
report
which you've uh condemned is going to
uh have a serious impact on the handling
of race masses in this country bearing
in mind
extremely heavy levels of criticism it's
come under
unprecedented levels of of criticism i
mean i just looked at the
british medical association letter which
represents 150 000 doctors
and medical students and they said we
gave evidence you didn't listen
and you misrepresented us it's not just
them it's the
it's the churches it's the mosque it's
the it's the academics
look this report started with its
conclusion
it's conclusion that systemic racism
doesn't exist in spite of the wealth of
evidence
i i think look the the big thing would
be
to say we made a mistake put it in the
bin
start afresh listen to people and give
people hope
when we do that adam when you put good
people in a room with a good heart and
hope
great things will happen but if you are
have blinkers on
and you are entrenched in denial then
what happens is that the same outcomes
that happened in the usa that can happen
here
will continue to occur lord wally thank
you very much indeed for joining us